what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i'm going to be reacting to kevin
samuels
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel my next goal is
20 000 subscribers
each and every one of you helps me get
to that goal while you're at it don't
forget to ring the bell as well
that way you're going to get notified of
my daily videos
okay i try to keep these short and sweet
for you guys my intros
this one's labeled this video is labeled
our modern women finish it is better to
be a baby mama than a wife
i can't imagine this is going to be
uplifting we'll see
do you have any kids yes i do i have too
so in other words
[ __ ] marriage but i have kids um
it wasn't really that me and their
father was together as teenagers
and just by the time we got to
uh the marian age i would say by the
time we were 23 24
looking towards marriage i was done with
the relationship
um he cheated a lot but you already had
the kids
yes we already had do you guys think
that you should
stay together if you have kids no matter
what
and if the answer is yes tell me why
and if the answer is no um tell me like
what the limit would be
so this one so i've said this before and
i said again black
women it seems like being a
being a wife is more of a big deal than
being a mother
for some people it was never that type
of thing to me and
maybe because of what i saw as far as
being a wife you know okay so so why
don't you okay so
i don't want to just assume but how do
you kids
14-9 14-9 yes
and how do you 33 33
yes so you had a kid at
18 or 19 years old and then another one
at
25 23 24 yes
all right so why was
marriage no big deal um
marriage was never a big deal on my
i i i would say because i
personally never um i think i have like
commitment phobia
almost like what like i have
a thing with commitment i just don't
personally believe
you know the violence but you that
you've made a baby with something i
don't see people live their lifestyle
basically so so another so what see this
doesn't make sense to me is make cause
like
phobias and commitment you committed to
being somebody's mama until you die
[Music]
what is it with women like yourself that
don't seem to realize that that's crazy
to us
meaning that you it's all right to be a
mama
and struggle or trying to make try to do
the job with two people
as one person well
actually i've never had to do the job as
far as their dad
by myself because their dad has always
been present however
um in a single mom aspect of you know us
living apart i live you know in my
separate state and live in yours
just because a child can be maintained
a roof over here food on this on a plate
and clothes on a bank does not mean a
child is being raised
the job trying to do the job of two
people means you're one person in the
house
correct that means there's a deficit
that means you're
one side you are unbalanced it's a
female's
way of looking at things with no man in
the house
see it's interesting because i have
friends
um whose like parents like dealt with
infidelity and i asked them like would
they
have preferred because their parents
like fought a lot or whatever my parents
usually weren't the parents that like
fought a ton
growing up so that's why i don't have a
ton of like experience with that
but i've asked i have two different
friends who are in that situation
and one of them told me she's happy her
parents like stuck through it and the
other told me that she wish
wished her parents got divorced years
ago
so because both of their parents are
still together now and
yeah it's interesting because that's
like my one i guess disagreement with
kevin samuels is he
acts like if you have a kid there's no
reason
to ever get divorced and i don't
i don't personally agree with that
because i think some people
are just so bad together that it's not a
good example for the kids
and as somebody who has had to try to do
things on the weekend
that's not the same
no that's not the same however that
doesn't mean every woman i don't
you get what i'm saying some women look
at marriage or being a wife as a pivotal
point
to success and in life that just never
been
you something so it's all right so it's
basically okay to walk around with you
and kids and no no structure no not me
and my kids are no structure yes we
probably should have more structure with
having a father in the home absolutely
it's more structured but it's okay for
me
to not be to be committed to being a
mother but not being committed to being
a wife
no it's not you know what i'm saying i
don't know see i don't get i get that
y'all want to believe that
but the the results are really clear
that's why the black community is at the
bottom
because there's so many women that like
yourself think all right i'll i'll i'll
commit to being a mother
let's see the listen now i'll let you
speak don't know don't don't let me
speak
and then your child is 14 to 9 you don't
know what it's going to be yet
you don't know until they're out of your
house and realize every 18 what kind of
people do we make
so you really don't know yet but what we
do know is the woman that came before
you
that have children and don't worry about
marriage do you have boys or girls
i have a son and a daughter so you don't
want your daughter to be married either
no not that i don't want my daughter to
be married if that's what she wants to
do she can but i've never made it
a priority or a thing for myself that's
just me
i don't think it was all right i have
not met i have not met the man
that i feel that i can commit to did you
feel like to me you could do what
that i could commit to with the way that
he acts just like perfect example
then why me so see ma'am all this stuff
would make sense if you wouldn't decide
to make it become a mother once or twice
and this is what i need you ladies to
start listening to
you close your mouth listen listen
listen
this is what's wrong for the
parliamentary community we got women
making stand this stuff and y'all don't
listen to the rep
this is why our community's jacked up
we got so many individual women talking
about well you know i don't need to
i don't i don't know a man who can do
this or that it's like well
who cares you you're somebody's mother
and we need families
yes we do need families but i do not
support
being a family with a male just because
you have a penis does not mean you can
leave
but then why have his babies
we have children just like people get
married and they get divorced it's the
same thing
no it's not it is not it is it
basically what you're saying is like so
many women whether you're married or not
man it don't matter because people can
divorce
with marriage
all things are equal it's always
relative and the problem is in our
community this is this is how women
think
it's no big deal whether you're married
or not just make the babies
and and have fractured broken homes
because no nobody else we didn't set up
to have a fractured or broken home
because we had i not left the
relationship had i
not left the relationship we would still
be together to this day
so you broke it like okay i say damn
she just proved his point she doesn't
even know
a lot of women records you wreck your
own homes
and that's not gonna work i've been
trying to be cool but when i start
talking you start talking
you directly with your man but you can't
do that but you do it to her you want to
wreck your home is cool
but this is why i'm going to give you
gender because you women don't even
listen to another point of view you're
not listening you don't
you're not listening get your little
captain friend and check her
check your tackling friend if you want
to talk with me
check your friend on bounce if she wants
to you know okay
tell her to bring herself on the screen
oh yeah
i don't do that that background in my
business tell your friend to get on here
you can't even control your friends this
is crazy
this is the [ __ ] we're talking i'm
seriously listen what just happened
i don't know a man that's good enough to
do such and so forth and who wants to be
dealing with some
foolishness like that
the only group of women that sit around
and try to justify and make it make
sense as to well you know i can go be a
a young my friends are not that wild
like they would not do that a teenage
mother at 18 to 19 years old when you
ain't got no business being a mother
not married and then go do it
again and then talk about the downsides
of it
ladies understand this is why so many
men feel like you're done
because listen to our little kaplan ass
friend in the background
and you're you're literally a direct
reflection
of who you keep around so if your
friends act like that that says
something about you you stay around them
this is it
it's no big deal to be a single mama
because relationships break up and see
all of this
is only an issue because you decided if
you wanted to just
if you just wanted to
let me help you out i can overtalk
anybody i want to on my show
see let me tell you something
you can't even come in here and have a
conversation when it gets contentious
with a man because the first thing so
many of our sisters want to do
is show your dick let me sit up let me
argue back and forth other than just sit
back and be quiet we already know what
you think
but to get a different point of view
what it would do is would actually
make her have to listen to another point
of view and it might put some
accountability and consequence
and that's it that's it that's why when
i walk around houston i got black men
damn near tears saying thank you brother
thank you thank you please keep saying
what you say so y'all
can miss with that [ __ ] i got too
many men out here
that are saying thank you for doing this
because that is what they have to deal
with
you don't even want to hear another
point of view that what why
that why not try to be with a man that
you want to be with
and then make babies until then well
i'll just talk about the man i chose to
make a baby and then tell you why
relationships are bad then stop being
mothers
are they done
are you done and if you can't even have
a conversation
what is it bold like what what think
about
the oh my goodness does he just keep
okay
yeah that's crazy
see it's interesting because me and my
parents never even talked about like
kids outside of marriage who's literally
just don't
have sex outside of marriage but let me
know in the comments what you guys think
um personally she really acted like a 15
year old to me i didn't
really get it um and it's crazy to me
that she really did not
understand that if you have like
like the gravity of having a kid but let
me know in the comments if you agree or
disagree do not forget to like comment
and subscribe
and i will talk to you guys next time